foreign
hi Christina how are you
great how are you better than I deserve
what's up
well thank you for taking my question
um I recently sat down with an
educational company that teaches you how
to use a HELOC as your primary mortgage
so I know that secondary helocs are a
terrible idea
but they had this idea of using a HELOC
as your primary and only loan at the
house so that like all of your
um deposits and of them your job and
everything are put directly in the HELOC
you still have access to it and so the
premise is used since you're putting
everything in it and you still have
access to it you can how does that that
scam is still around I thought that
thing had died this is not an
educational company this is a scam
okay
they're not educational at all
no so their premise is is that you use
the HELOC and you pay all your bills out
of the hay lock HELOC and then you use
your uh uh your income and it's direct
deposited to pay down the HELOC each
month so you're using your HELOC much
like a checking account as if that's
some Advantage Because by the way when
all the money comes in and all the money
goes out the same amounts left in there
whether it's a checking account or a
HELOC there's no magic to a HELOC
okay you follow me
what is your income what's your income
um see combined is around 1 30. okay
thousand okay so let's call let's just
make it up ten thousand dollars a month
okay
right okay so you put ten thousand
dollars a month on your HELOC direct
deposited reduce your HELOC by ten
thousand dollars from your income this
month right then you use your HELOC and
you pay all your bills to the tune of
ten thousand dollars and the HELOC
balance goes back up
yeah
you follow me
there's absolutely no change
this is just a checking account
and these guys act like it's mystical
magical and does something different it
doesn't do a dead gum thing it makes
them Rich so it does that
you're paying them a fee for their
education
but yeah you follow me there's no
Advantage at all zero
if you want to pay down your mortgage
all mortgages are calculated on simple
interest
so when you pay down your mortgage it
always reduces the amount of interest
you are paying the next month a hundred
percent of them
okay HELOC or otherwise HELOC simple
interest also so it does not get you out
of debt any faster than a traditional
mortgage by the fact that you're running
your bills in and out of a HELOC and
your income in and out of a HELOC it's
just circular you should the p is still
under the shell does this make sense
okay you follow me my apology and what
was the purpose in getting the HELOC
what made you go I'm interested in this
no because they sold you suckered into
this education company they're the HELOC
she wasn't looking for a HELOC they were
looking for her right
uh yes
um I was looking at uh that's in the ads
about
um how you can pay your house off really
fast and I just was curious and I
haven't done it yet I just let me just
let me let's try let's try again okay
just to make really sure you understand
because I don't I'm not 100 I got
through so the way the house is paid off
is when you pay down the principal
running your bills in and out of the
house your income into the house your
bills back out of the house does not pay
down the principal
if out of your ten thousand you wanted
to reduce principal three thousand you
could just take three thousand out of
your checking account put it on
principle if you put nothing on
principle principal's not going down you
put three thousand on principle that's
the only way the house is paid off
it does not get paid off because you ran
your bills in and out of it
that does nothing to pay off your house
the only thing that pays off your house
is you pay on the principal that's the
only way that's the only way their
system works but they've got this little
uh chart crap that they show you that
you're going to use so much of your
income to actually reduce principal well
duh of course you can do that anyway and
you don't need them so no run from this
please please run from this how much
mortgage are you talking about taking
out
uh well we just recently bought our
house so um we owe around 290. oh okay
just leave that alone then just just
leave these people alone
have I convinced you please yeah okay
right run from Isis averted education
company that's my favorite part of their
marketing scheme yeah I met with this
education company yeah yeah they were
educating you
so um yeah okay so that I thought that
thing man I haven't seen that scam in
probably a decade a lot of this crap's
coming back around though too it's like
fashion Tic Tac is bringing a lot of it
back that's true well the whole life is
a whole nother generation that hasn't
been screwed yet so we got to bring back
all the old scams and you know get to
the get to the young people well back in
your day that you had to seek out stupid
now it just shows up in your face at 60
seconds at a time from some slick guy
yeah your algorithm will help you get
there for sure
um yeah but yeah and the other one was
the um what's the thing called the whole
life savings program a 707 or 770
whatever oh remember that one no it's
the same kind of crap but it's a whole
life agent a whole whole life I know
infinite banking that's the one that's
the one okay that's the one but it's got
It's got a number to it that they use
but it's you know it's also just a
complete it's the life a scam I don't
mean criminally illegal
I just mean it's so stupid it should be
Criminal
that's what I mean by scam it's just oh
like you can Dave debt is tax free you
can borrow from yourself
exactly that whole idea yeah yeah
because 100 of the time you borrow money
borrow money's not taxable people it's
not income
and if you borrow your own money
yeah it's not taxable either and you're
stupid
because you just paid interest to borrow
your own money you're pulling a fast one
on you that's you you got them buddy you
you got the guy oh wait a minute the
guy's me oh crap you just think about
this stuff long enough you should back
yourself off the ledge the problem is
it's all impulsive and a guy told you
and they man and a tick tock I always
tell you that too the other thing the
thing about the infinite Banking and
these guys here too is you will get
screwed More Often by an enthusiastic
ignoramus
then you will by an actual con artist
because some of these morons actually
believe this stuff
and they because they believe it they
can make you believe it but it's uh yeah
enthusiastic Remus says there's a lot
more of those than actual con artists
they're the same ones selling you a star
in the galaxy Dave with your name on it
those are the same guys they just
switched businesses
it's called an nft Now Dave look into it
you own it I promise
it's virtual ownership I mean just think
about that this is the Ramsay show